hi there steve kaufman again uh it's
kind of a
not such a great day here in vancouver
so
i've decided to follow up my my previous
um video on the subject of the best way
to learn
a language
and i'm now going to talk about how do
we get to
a conversational level in a language
because that was a question that was
asked on my youtube channel
so
uh i think all of you know that that
have followed some of my videos
you know that i believe very much in the
importance of input
um
most of my language learning uh
certainly in over the last
i guess since 1980
where i have uh learned uh
or very much improved in a bunch of
languages
um it's been based on input listening
and reading initially uh in the 80s
finding books with word lists in german
and italian and
spanish
and then
i guess for the last 10 years
taking advantage of mp3 players and
stuff like that working on cantonese
and russian and korean and portuguese
and and certainly very much improving
basically in all of my languages
primarily using input listening and
reading and of course using our website
at link
but the question is
you know when do we get to convert to
being comfortable in conversations okay
here's my take on this to be good at
conversations you have to have a lot of
sustained
conversations
um so if you have let's say a limited
vocabulary but you happen to spend
two weeks in mexico
you may
achieve a certain level of
conversational
fluency
using the very limited vocabulary that
you have so that you may be able to go
to a restaurant and between pointing and
gestures and and saying things you'll be
able to communicate in spanish and order
and and so forth and and that'll give
you a certain sense of satisfaction
if you come
back to wherever you're from and you
don't have that opportunity you'll very
quickly
lose that conversational ability
um
for me for example i remember that i
spent a fair amount of time on input in
portuguese
went to portugal
but
partly because i was with my wife so we
were speaking english all the time but i
found it very difficult
to have any
meaningful conversation with portuguese
people
um
because i couldn't follow very well what
they were saying because they spoke
english much better than i spoke
portuguese
uh and so forth
i remember even after several months of
on and off working on portuguese i'd be
invited to a function where there are a
lot of brazilians and i really couldn't
follow the conversation even though i
had spanish
so
but then i put in
an additional three months and by that
time we had better content in our
library at link plus i did i got to
where i could start to understand
certain podcasts from portugal and i did
a lot of listening to them
and all of a sudden i went to portugal
again and this time i could now converse
and i could converse on quite a wide
variety of things again very much helped
by my spanish but at least i could
understand what they were saying so to
me
conversational you know if you want to
be conversational within a very limited
range
of subjects and and limited vocabulary
if you have that sustained opportunity
to use the limited vocabulary that you
have you can probably get comfortable in
in sort of greetings and asking for a
few things and
and smiling at the right time and so
forth
uh if you want to be able to
have more meaningful conversations
you still need to have that exposure
like again i'm wandering a bit here but
i spent a month in italy with my wife
but i was exposed to a lot of italian
did manage to speak some italian in
meaningful situations there's no
question that i came back my italian was
much improved
much improved so that that regular
exposure to the language is what's going
to finally make you conversational and
you'll be conversational at whatever
level
that you have achieved through your
input activities so if you have had
limited input activity you have a
limited vocabulary you can nevertheless
achieve a certain level of
conversational comfort just using those
words
and that kind of it can give you that
sort of get your your fingers on the
ledge now so you can start crawling up
and participate in more conversations
and then you'll hear more so it'll still
be
the input that's going to increase your
word power so that you can then
understand more and participate in more
in more conversations however
uh
if you continue to focus on input
then
when you finally do get that
sustained exposure conversational
exposure
then you'll be you'll be able to be
conversational at a much higher level
so the question was you know how long
how much input does it require to become
become conversational
i would turn around and say you know at
what level do you want to be
conversational in my own case i want to
be conversational at a level where i
understand most of what is said or i can
talk about a lot of different subjects
and therefore i tend to delay
putting myself in a situation where i
get a lot of sustained
exposure to conversation
now how much is required if i have
spanish and i want to be comfortably
conversational in portuguese if i have
an hour a day to spend then i say i
think six months is enough if i have
more than an hour if i have two hours a
day three hours a day i could reduce
that down to two or three months that's
going from spanish to portuguese
because again my main thing is i want to
understand what they're saying
uh
if and that would be true basically for
all romance languages possibly french is
a little more difficult
russian
i've been working at for
four years plus
uh i understand very well now i in some
ways i understand the political
discussion in russian better than in i
would say
in some of the languages that i speak
better because i've been listening to so
much political discussion in russian
anejo muslim
however when i speak i'm clumsy i
struggle to express certain things i
know that i make a lot of mistakes
now if i had if i had the opportunity to
have
sustained exposure to russian
for a month
i know that my conversational ability
would go way up
but again to answer the question if it's
six months
to get comfortably conversational at a
decent level with decent vocabulary
in portuguese going from spanish
i've taken four years in russia now if
at the end of two years i had gone to
russia for
two months one month my conversational
ability would have gone up but i would
have been at a lower level in terms of
vocabulary but
i don't know i would say with russian or
chinese operating on the basis of one
uh hour a day i think anywhere from two
to four years
is is realistic
uh in terms of of being able to to to
speak intelligently and understand i i
stressed like to my mind conversation is
two-way conversation is not just about
you saying something and then just being
lost when the person replies
conversational implies a more or less
balanced exchange
and and where the other person doesn't
have to make too many allowances for you
and and where you don't give the
impression of not understanding
so
you know it depends what your ambitions
are in terms of conversational if
if you just want to ask for the bathroom
and order some food and and
exchange some pleasantries and tell them
your name and where you live and how
much you like your country then that can
come of course much earlier
but
my preference is to be comfortable in a
variety of circumstances and so i would
say
from english with no previous experience
in language learning
the first language is going to be very
tough there is no question i should
mention this as well that as i have
learned more and more languages over the
last 10 years i've improved in all of
them
language
learning is is a skill there's a
language learning fitness level that you
achieve by doing it so the first new
language you learn is more
very difficult the second one gets
easier and it just gets easier and
easier as you go
so conclusion
if it's a relate very closely related
language i would still say six months
like spanish to italian if it's not
related and you're new at it say from
english to french or english to german
one hour a day i would look at one to
two years if it's a difficult language
like russian or chinese i would go two
to four years based on one hour a day of
input based learning but you can choose
to take the plunge anytime you want and
you will achieve greater conversational
ability when you expose yourself to that
greater you know
sustained conversation but unless you
focus
and continue to focus your efforts on
input your vocabulary will remain
sort of stagnant and your ability to
understand won't progress and so i think
that ability to understand is a big part
of of conversation
uh conversational fluency so i hope that
answers the question that someone i
can't remember who mednos there we are
asked on my youtube channel thank you
for listening